[Música]
porque el mundo está lleno de genios
pobres
esta es una pregunta que me intriga
muchísimo
vincent van gogh
una de las mentes más creativas y más
geniales de la historia de la humanidad
sus pinturas el día de hoy se
comercializan cada una en valores
superiores a 80 o 90 millones de dólares
sin embargo
este genio creativo vivió en la pobreza
y murió en la pobreza absoluta
y la irrelevancia total la gente
poderoso es eso como puede ser posible
el problema que tuvo vincent
es el problema que tú y yo tenemos que
la sociedad tiene el sistema educativo
tradicional la sociedad de la cual
formamos parte nos ha enseñado
exitosamente a vender productos y
servicios pero no nos ha enseñado a
vendernos al nivel de nuestros talentos
y nuestras capacidades y yo vengo a
hablarte el día de hoy de una
herramienta poderosa que va a cambiar tu
vida el branding personal es una
metodología que te va a permitir
venderte en el verdadero valor que te
mereces en un valor que va a la altura
de tus capacidades y de tus talentos
vengo a hablarte de branding personal y
antes te quiero contar cómo llegué yo al
branding personal hace 13 años yo
estudié ingeniería industrial en una
buena universidad en la ciudad de mexico
y cuando salí a la carrera muy
emocionado fui a buscar empleo
metí mi currículum a las bolsas de
trabajo y empecé a asistir a entrevistas
fui a una entrevista y no recibí una
oferta laboral fui a dos y no recibí a
tres y no recibí terminé asistiendo a 44
procesos de reclutamiento diferentes
sabes cuántas ofertas recibí
es un momento trascendental para mí
porque es cuando decido dejar de ser una
víctima y tomo responsabilidad de mis
circunstancias es el momento en el que
entendí que no sabía venderme y ahí es
donde surge mi pasión por el branding
personal y el día de hoy voy a compartir
te una herramienta que he trabajado en
los últimos 10 años en los cuales me he
especializado en este gran tema del
branding personal te presento el
triángulo del branding personal que está
compuesto por la gran promesa por el
héroe que la cumple y por la validación
hablemos sobre la gran promesa y para
ello te presento a una delincuente y
mira qué poderosa imagen esta imagen fue
tomada el día de su detención
esta mujer era una ciudadana común que
abordó un autobús de pasajeros
ella sabía que por el color de su piel
tenía que sentarse en la parte trasera
del autobús
y por si había alguna duda el mismo
autobús tenía letreros que decían
personas de color en la parte de atrás
blancos en la parte de enfrente
ella es rosa parks y decidió sentarse en
la parte de enfrente cuál fue su promesa
la igualdad
este personaje que posiblemente conoces
su gran promesa salvar a la humanidad
y es irrelevante la pregunta de si la
humanidad necesita que la salven o de si
él puede salvarla lo importante es que
los que entendió los dos grandes
elementos
de una promesa poderosa el primero es
que tienes que decirle con claridad a tu
audiencia cuál es el problema que quiere
resolver salvar a la humanidad
vamos a marte
y el segundo elemento que entendió
perfectamente es el supo identificar
quién es su comunidad quién es su tribu
otro personaje importante en la historia
make américa great game y volvemos a lo
mismo es irrelevante la pregunta de si
américa dejó de ser grandiosa
donald trump entendió lo mismo que el on
mars que entendió cómo comunicar
claramente el problema que resolvía y
segundo supo identificar a su comunidad
y a su tribu
winston churchill primer ministro
británico año 1940 él tenía que tomar
una decisión trascendental que cambiaría
el rumbo de la historia
pelearía contra los nazis o negociaría y
él tenía muchísima presión sobre todo de
ciertos grupos sociales para que
negociara y el decidió pelear
su discurso uno de los más famosos de la
historia está compuesto por un par de
términos muy poderosos en donde él llega
y dice
wizard no te sorprender no nos
rendiremos
la victoria
sin importar que el camino para llegar a
ella sea largo y tedioso su promesa la
libertad
y yo te invito a que reflexiones en este
momento
tú que tienes que crear una gran promesa
como la puedes comunicar claramente y
que identifiques a tu comunidad ya tu
tribu el segundo gran elemento del
triángulo del branding personal el héroe
toda gran promesa necesita un héroe que
la cumpla
te presento a uno los estrategas
militares más importantes de la historia
esta persona además de librar grandes
batallas de manera victoriosa
creo la primera universidad para mujeres
de europa trajo la ilustración a su país
y esta persona que estás bien
no es un hombre es una mujer es catalina
la grande
uno de los personajes más importantes de
la historia de europa y particularmente
de rusia porque una de las mujeres más
elegantes
femeninas e inteligentes de europa
encomendó la creación de esta pintura
que hoy cuelga en el legendario museo
del hermitage en rusia porque tiene
rasgos masculinos en esta pintura porque
ella entendió los dos grandes elementos
que un héroe debe de tener el primero
es el carácter no existe una sola
persona
que haya cambiado al mundo o que haya
logrado una gran promesa
que ti tuve que dude
todo gran héroe
proyecta certidumbre el segundo elemento
que entendió perfectamente es la imagen
diferenciada
este es otro personaje importante de la
historia que entendió también estos dos
grandes elementos le ha dado certidumbre
a su tribu y también entendió el arte
maravilloso de crear el personaje
fíjate qué sutil fue la evolución de
este personaje que él mismo creó y qué
poderoso se ve en sus últimos años con
una identidad diferenciada
general douglas macarthur
el militar más condecorado en la
historia del ejército de los estados
unidos de norteamérica
comandante supremo
de la fuerza aliada durante la segunda
guerra mundial en la zona del pacífico
él logró batallar y vencer
a los japoneses que los expertos
militares de la época decían que eran
imposibles de vencer
el general macarthur entendió también
estos dos grandes elementos uno
certidumbre y segundo la imagen
diferenciada
una imagen habla más que mil palabras yo
te invito en este momento
conéctate con tu certidumbre
y es el momento de que construyas tu
personaje diferenciado tu héroe que
cumple la gran promesa el tercer gran
elemento la validación
imagina que te invito a comer un
restaurante llegamos a parís una de las
ciudades más hermosas del mundo
yo no he asistido a este restaurante
pero me lo recomendaron
y cuando llegamos las mesas están
ocupadas y hay 15 personas haciendo fila
tú crees que es un buen restaurante
como tenemos ganas de comerme ese
restaurante te digo que regresemos una
hora y media después seguramente habrá
menos personas y cuando regresamos una
hora y media después ya no hay 15
personas en la fila ahora y 60 personas
en la fila tú tienes alguna duda de que
ese restaurante es bueno
en mis conferencias presenciales hago la
pregunta de si alguien cree que el
restaurante es bueno más del 97 por
ciento de los asistentes levantan la
mano y dicen si este restaurante es
delicioso fíjate qué curioso ni tú ni yo
ni estos amigos asistentes
hemos estado en este restaurante este es
el poder de la validación
te presento a un genio loco
este personaje vivió ciertos eventos
sumamente fuertes durante su vida su
esposa se quitó la vida y él tuvo varios
retos de salud muy importantes y en su
búsqueda de mejorar la salud él empezó a
experimentar con baños de agua helada
y él empezó a detectar que su cuerpo
reaccionaba de manera positiva a este
frío
y empezó a comunicarlo amigos a
conocidos se empezó a acercar a
reporteros pero nadie le hacía caso y no
fue hasta que este genio entendió el
poder de una validación extrema que es
lo que te quiero invitar hoy a que tú
logres en tu promesa
winehouse se puso unas sandalias se puso
unos shorts y escaló el everest sin
equipo de protección
a partir de ese momento
no hubo nadie que dudará de su capacidad
a partir de ese momento él logró crear
uno de los movimientos en pro de la
salud más importantes del mundo wind of
entendió la gran promesa que es un
cambio radical en la salud él entendió
el héroe porque él es un personaje
altamente diferenciado con un fuerte
carácter y finalmente entendió el poder
de una validación
extrema y yo te invito a que a partir de
hoy te beneficies de este triángulo del
branding personal para que puedas lograr
tu gran promesa y así servir a la
sociedad el mundo está lleno de genios
pobres pero no tiene que ser así
vincent van gogh no vivió para disfrutar
los frutos de su talento de su capacidad
pero tú sí puedes yo sí puedo y este es
el momento en donde a través del
branding personal puedes cambiar tu vida
muchas gracias
[Música]
ah